creo que muchos de ustedes podrán
reconocer este tarrito azul de aquí si
la leche de magnesia cuando yo era
chiquitito esto era infaltable en el
botiquín de mi casa mi abuela decía que
era importante tomar purgante así que
constantemente me daban unas cucharadas
de este jarabe blanco y viscoso que teja
así con la boca seca por suerte ahora
hay estos jugos detox que no saben tan
mal y aquí yo tuve como la oportunidad
de experimentar algo después de una
semana de haber tomado estos batidos
verdes que lo que hacen es ayudarte a
desintoxicar su cuerpo y fue ahí donde
sentí como este bienestar no sé cómo que
mi estómago se sentía mucho más ligero
entonces la sabiduría de la abuela hace
completo sentido hay que tomar purgante
porque nos alimentamos todos los días y
no necesariamente prestamos mucha
atención a lo que consumimos al final
del día se depositan nuestros estómagos
sabían que nuestro estómago es
considerado como nuestro segundo cerebro
pero yo me pregunto entonces qué pasa
con el primero es decir qué pasa con
nuestras mentes que al final también
todos los días consume información
estímulos de emociones sensaciones
etcétera le damos un purgante a nuestras
mentes
a este esta situación actual nos llegó a
todos a vivir unos cambios
inesperados pero además ha incrementado
la cantidad de tiempo que pasamos
expuestos a las pantallas y todo lo que
consumimos de esas que por lo general no
es lo más saludable por otro lado este
nuevo comportamiento social que nos
vemos obligados a vivir que es tan
distinto creo que ha exacerbado un
montón ciertos pensamientos y
sensaciones los sentimientos en relación
a los estímulos externos y cómo
reaccionamos ante ellos haciéndonos
quizás un poco más sensibles menos
tolerantes es como que nuestras mentes
empiezan a estar invadidas de un montón
de pensamientos que a veces por lo
general se convierten en emociones
negativas en esta especie de tensión
emocional en la primera semana de
cuarentena ya luego de pasar con todos
los sumidos de skype con mis amigos
empecé poco a poco a tener más espacio
para mí a estar más de soledad y es ahí
donde empecé a hacer
quizás el incremento de estas emociones
que empezaban como en el miedo luego
iban como a la incertidumbre y luego
quizás terminaban como en la ira pasada
así como enojado supongo porque me daba
cuenta que ya no puedo hacer lo que
estaba acostumbrado a hacer de mi vida
constantemente había días donde me
levantaba como deprimido sin tener mucha
idea de cuál era la razón trataba de
hablar con alguien de hacer deporte
incluso un poco de yoga no sé y si todo
ayudaba pero quizás mi mente estaba tan
empachada que esta obra mental seguía
ocupando espacio haciéndome sentir como
ansioso e incómodo así que decidí buscar
una solución sustentable para esto y me
di cuenta de una cosa que todos tenemos
una capacidad y esa capacidad de la
capacidad de crear esto es lo que ha
llevado a la humanidad a evolucionar al
punto en dónde estamos y creo que el
humano es el único que puede imaginar
cosas y luego hacerlo
realidad así que decidí iniciar con este
experimento que además toma como
referencia al teatro griego que era como
un puente para que la gente pueda purgar
sus emociones sin filtros sin crítica
sin juicio podían sentir no sé amor odio
tristeza miedo era como su leche de
magnesia
dividir esto en una obra de tres actos
entonces empecé en el acto uno por lo
más fácil no lo más simple que era
empezar a escribir todas las cosas que
pasaban por mi mente
pero aún así seguía existiendo como esta
sensación de estar en pasado en mi mente
así que hacia el acto 2 cogí todos estos
microrrelatos de estas micro historias
que habían sido resultado de lo que
había escrito y decidí ponerlas en un
medio menos explícito quizás más
abstracto así que tomé mi guitarra y
empecé a componer unos riffs que estaban
asociados con estos estas historias y
sus emociones y de esta manera empecé a
construir ese puente mi guitarra empezó
a hacer ese puente para empezar a
vomitar todo esto que sentía de igual
sin filtros sin juicios aquí quiero
hacer un paréntesis para esto no en
realidad no tienes que ser
necesariamente una artista por eso
insisto en que todos los humanos tenemos
una capacidad creadora puedes hacer
máscaras velas postres pasteles bailar
creé un montón de cosas que podemos usar
en pro de purgar nuestras mentes
regresando al acto 3 aquí en cambio
encontré una oportunidad que fue
aventurarme a un medio que antes no
había usado y empecé a hacer estas
pseudo ilustraciones que me permitían
seguir llevando a esto a una abstracción
de lo que puede aprender aprendí que los
pensamientos negativos de esta atención
emocional no es tan fácil de limpiar a
veces son como un poco engañoso si
tratan de o se esconden y aparecen de
nuevo entonces mientras más lo podemos
abstraer mientras más lo podemos
depositar en algo externo es es mucho
más posible que se integren y que te
sientas como más tranquilo yo ya me
siento muy menos ansioso y mucho más en
paz
otra cosa que puedo destacar de este
experimento fue increíble es que pude
conectar con una serie de artistas super
increíbles que lo que hicieron es leer
estas estás
microhistorias ver cual conectaba con
sus emociones y decidieron ponerle una
melodía cantaba eso fue increíble porque
este proyecto que había empezado como
una purga muy personal se convirtió ya
en una creación que cogió una forma muy
linda y que además se convirtió en
nuestra propia leche de magnesia que por
cierto no sabe tan feo como la que me
daban de niño
entonces hoy puedo decir que nuestra
capacidad creator creadora no solamente
nos sirve para purgar sino que además
nos sirve para poder colaborar para
poder generar una conexión que si bien
si es todo y tenemos que es un que me
skype que la tecnología como un medio
que ha ayudado no todos a seguir
conectados pero creo que cuando
colaboramos construimos un vínculo
porque estamos trabajando en pro de algo
mayor y creo que en esta situación
actual una de las cosas súper importante
es no perder estos vínculos o no perder
la capacidad de crear nuevos vínculos
así que considero que es importantísimo
que cuidemos de nosotros no solo con la
distancia social o lavándonos las manos
muchas veces al día dato importantísimo
sino también que prestemos atención a
las cosas que estamos viendo o
escuchando y como decía la abuela de vez
en cuando darle una pulga a nuestras
mentes encuentra cuál es tu leche de
magnesia y que ésta te ayude a pasar por
este tiempo súper difícil y que te
puedan mantener cuerdo y saludable
gracias